dites-nous vraiment pour vous qui est le
meilleur animateur vraiment celui que
vous trouvez le meilleur est celui que
vous trouvez le moins bon techniquement
je dis pas ce celui que vous aimez ou
celui que vous n'aimez pas parce que
voilà ça paye jean luc reichmann pour
moi c'est un des meilleurs animateurs
voilà du paf dit la vérité un
franchement bernard il ya une
distinction à faire entre animateurs de
jeux et animateur de débat par exemple
mais là je vous parle l'animateur de
divertissement pur divertissement alors
nagui pour moi nadi pour vous et le vélo
ou le moins bon profond celui qui
voudrait qu'ils vous accrocher non mais
c'est pas vous la croyez moi et vous
pouvez ne pas aimer make me trouvais bon
mais un mec tout vous n'aimez vous
trouvez moins bon le flop le flop
j'avoue que je ne sais pas la teneur si
d'accord je pense que ce qui est
meilleur techniquement en divertissement
c'est nikos et le moins bon david ginola
d'accord techniquement c'est vous en
divertissement mais bien sûr que oui
syrie on l'a vu encore dans little big
star vous pouvez aller d'un registre à
l'autre avec les enfants vous êtes
vraiment de pêcheurs non non non mais
c'est aussi dire que c'est vous et en
revanche mois dans le show j'aime -
laurent ruquier j'accroche - avec son
côté show j'aime pas j'aime pas ça c'est
franchement moi je trouve vraiment que
c'est vous non mais a enlevé on aimerait
tous avoir un prof comme vous à l'école
ya contrôle non on change tout on fait
ce que c'est c'est vraiment je suis pas
sur un vélo qui nous regardent les mici
jab à nous l'an prochain mais quand son
fils est celui que malade tu trouves le
bourrin je suis désolé de dire ça
beaugrand maintenant la question comment
manette ne soit pas désolé avec lui et
la pub avec vous référer à vannes où il
y en a beaucoup de la paix thibault un
mois par et thibault il apprit que des
notes mon frère le gaz sur la vie de ma
mère il croit qu'il est dans des paroles
et des actes
j'ai pas pris que des notes mais le
meilleur animateur pour moi c'est vous
aimez franchement au-delà de tout le
monde savait depuis le début que je lui
dis je suis tes pmp mai or vous je
dirais pareil que maxime gyselinck
hausse nikos pareil et en que j'aime le
moins qui est pour moi le moins violent
c'est cyril féraud
cyril féraud allons d'abord elle a
vraiment eu envie d'avoir son avis
puisque là il va bien moi je dans le
divertissement pur
je pense que l'un des meilleurs c'est
moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais il dit la vérité honnêtement et
après on est noir le gris scandale est
énorme et je pense que dans les moins
beaux effectivement je trouve que ginola
et et est d'un classicisme un peu un peu
déconcertant en même temps il commence
alors qu'il aurait été sur france 2 vous
auriez pensé wendy nelles est sûre c'est
l'animateur qui avait déçu jean on a été
bon tout de suite là bas non mais les
mecs vous dire un truc quand on débute
moi j'adore david et je trouve bonbons
en plus mais hey mec ça c'est pas çà çà
çà sent je veux pas longtemps de ça
quand on est sur m6 on doit être déjà au
top et pour moi il est très bon mais je
vous le dis on doit être déjà au top
c'est pour va pas dire sur m6 chez un
animateur qui débute ça n'existe pas
excusez moi bachiri autres agapes basser
dans la gueule comme benjamin a été très
bon sur tahiti quest dont tahiti douche
aussi
[Applaudissements]
comment commence en douceur dahouët moi
j'adore cyril féraud et pour citer une
si j'adore sophie davant boccolini
j'aime pas du tout par contrat ouais
ouais
oui bah non mais elle est là les
manières mais je lui dire ce qu'elle
veut mais ce que j'ai dit quelque chose
pareil comme ça toujours des têtes
suivant benjamin j'aime beaucoup
il y eut enfin réaliser réellement
qu'une nation c'est ça je moi c'est moi
on n'a déjà rien arrangé mais qu'est ce
qui lie un petit bout c'est la jumbo
large audience
thibauld vous aime pas mais bon avec
l'intervention qui vient de faire on
peut voir que de boulot si tu vis alors
il faut savoir reconnaître son talent
alors donc manama et celui que tableau
face celui que j'aime pas rares mais
celui que tu trouves le moins bon c'est
même pas que tu aimes pas parce que
ouais on peut ne pas aimer quelqu'un ait
trouvé bon c'est vrai nous le moins bon
natural pastures pascal riché isabel
allende moi les meilleurs c'est la
guillou reichmann outre vous bien sûr on
le dit quand vous dites que c'est le
prof qu'on aimerait avoir c'est le prof
qu'on aimerait voir mais c'est le pauvre
qu'on n'en voit pas que notre système
[Rires]
est le moins de monde honnêtement moi
j'aime moins la présentation de lycos
que je trouve très classique mais elle
dit je le dis ouais ouais le penser si
on peut dire qu'il est mauvais dans dix
ou moins sensible nature ben oui je suis
vous êtes vous sensible en ce moment
juste le meilleur pour moi le meilleur
pour moi c'est stéphane plaza ah oui non
ça donnerait pas la pression de gagner
tellement il est naturel mieux les
panneaux ici le pire je voulais dire
yann barthez mais qu on aurait eu un
très bon camp mis ma mère je veux dire
castaldi la loi autour de la tombe dit
la vérité et qui part vous le monde
alors pour moi le
le mauvais celui que je n'aime pas parce
qu'il ne fait que lire un prompteur il
n'a pas de talent c'est yann barthès
d'accord du tout il dit ce qu'il pense
et coûtera voilà la droite gaston à
l'ailé chéri ben voilà il l'a dit il a
dit il le dit